das ist eine ganz besondere stunde jetzt
bei bild live denn alles dreht sich um
diesen mann der auf rechts steht obwohl
seit 14 tagen putins bomben fallen auf
sein land floh tobias zielinski jetzt
ist er bei paul ronzheimer bei unser
bild reporter in kiew das
exklusiv-interview mit flottem selensky
dem man auf dem die welt schaut bei bild
bei
prozent wir sind im präsidenten gebäude
von kirche sitzen hier zusammen mit dem
mann der stunde
herr präsident die menschen in
deutschland tragen jetzt wie haben sie
das durchschlagende sie jemals
das wie sie
sie haben ja zeit gefunden und zu
unterstützen danke für ihre
unterstützung
in einer
autoren
auf die straße mit der fahne der
freiheit das alles haben sie in ihren
ländern
obwohl es das ist die liebe zu unserem
land
und ich habe auch meine pflichten als
präsident ich muss da sein wo mein volk
ist das ist ja sagt und was angeht wie
lange ich schlafen kann ich diese
geheimnis nicht vor unserem plan
verraten er muss wissen wir sind aus
eisen und können wochen land unser land
verteidigen
wir sehen zahlreiche videos ihrer frau
und ihrer von lunge
system auf der tour des liste moskaus
ist dänischer gucken was macht das mit
ihrer premiere
in sicherheit
aber sie verstehen mich und unterstützen
eine entscheidung weil sie für unser
land ist
sie wollen dass kirchtag
bleibt
als menschen machen sie sich sorgen um
mich im herzen
leid dass ich euch
das ist
der moment in unserem limas in der
geschichte unseres landes
und wir leben ja nun in diesem moment
später werden wir uns daran erinnern wie
schwer dieser zeit war wie schlecht es
jedem einzelnen menschen in unserem land
jetzt
aber wir werden uns vielmehr an die
momente erinnern in denen wir etwas
aufgehalten waren etwas verändert habe
und
dass ich an meinem volk
die stärkung unseres landes
dass unser land unabhängig bleibt
ich mache es für meine kinder und für
meine enkelkinder
sie sollen wissen dass ihr vater der
präsident war und kein schwächling
die welt fragt sich wie radio russen
sind
tagesstunden vielleicht wie sie selbst
haben sie denn eigentlich kreis sind und
der russischen armee nach
straße nach ihr sind produziert
aber wir sind ja hier
wir sind ja hier in kiel
und die situation in ihr könnt hier
persönlich einschätzen
ich mache mir keine gedanken der feind
sich versteckt oder genial zu uns
gekommen ist
ich mache mir gedanken um unser land
über die wasserversorgung über die
nahrungsversorgung über mariupol
die bizarre milito
die situation furchtbar ist
die städte die blockiert sind die
menschen sind ohne wasser und nahrung
gestern ist ein mädchen wiegen die
notierung gestorben
da ist jetzt die humanitäre katastrophe
aus verschiedenen städten unseres landes
wurden die cologne humanitäre hilfe da
hingeschickt
mit nahrung und wasser aber ist die
werten beschlossen hat von der
russischen soldaten
das sind tapfere fahrer nicht alles aber
ist sie machen überschuss weiter
gestern glaub ich hatten wir uns auf
eine zusammenarbeit mit dem roten kreuz
geeignet
ich verstehe dass wir uns als menschen
immer um das eigene leben sorgen
das ist klar trotzdem machen sie weiter
die ganze welt
ist für ein ist nicht für ein krieg
vorbereitet wir haben wir keine
universallösung oder schritte die wir
vornehmen können
wir haben aber realen terror in unserer
geschichte
die starke arme hat
jetzt die okkupierten gebiete verlassen
viele diplomaten haben auch unser land
zu lassen
die zusammenarbeit mit dem roten kreuz
weitergebe
ich habe angst dass kiwi umschlossen
wird
ich habe keine angst ich
darf keine angst haben ich bleibe ruhig
wissen sie
was ist das schlimmste was passieren
könnte
wir haben
so viele menschen
was könnte noch schlimmer passieren für
die menschen die ihre kinder verloren
haben
wir dürfen nicht aufgeben und wir werden
nicht aufgeben
die haben
wir haben so viele menschen verloren
im ausland sind sie enttäuscht vom
kanzler scholz wird vom deutschen volk
[Musik]
es kann die handlungen
deutschen menschen nicht beurteilen
sie denken in erster linie an ihr
eigenes land
das ist ja auch
viele menschen in deutschland
unterstützen die ukraine die
demonstrieren für ukraine
der bundeskanzler jede art von menschen
gewählt
und seine politik für eine regierung ist
ja die politik seines landes
ich denke
sie sind ja zurückhaltend zu uns ja
gesehen einige schritte die uns
unterstützen lebens aktionen und
weiteren
unterstützen munition
wir sehen was deutschland machen
aber ich möchte herrn scholz und seinen
tieren
nicht beurteilen
das werde ich im nachhinein machen muss
wenn die ergebnisse dieser zeit sehen
sind wie es ausgeht
wann der krieg endet wie viele opfer es
gibt
jeder sieg hat viele eltern
wir danken dafür dass wir haben
aber der große fehler liegt jetzt auch
in der fotografie weil das da leiten die
einfachen leute für uns
ist jede minute wertvoll und die jede
minute kann menschen sterben wir haben
über mein opel gesprochen vor einigen
minuten
wurde die kinder carina
geschossen ich habe gerade die nachricht
bekommen dass
die kinderklinik angegriffen wurde ich
habe noch keine informationen über opfer
befohlen
ich hoffe sehr dass mal verstecken
konnten
wie kann sowas sein
eine rakete fliegt in die kinder
sind tiere die so was veranlassen
deswegen alle regierungen die
zurückhaltend zu unserer situation soll
sich gedanken machen haben sie kinder
und wenn eine rakete ein geburtshaus in
deutschland treffen würde was dann
stellen sie sich mal in ihrer situation
und dann würde gesprächen an verhandeln
das so läuft nicht schnell das ist auch
eine antwort wie das ist aber unser
schmerz beute und ich brauche sie lösen
wollte ich mir ich wünsche nicht im
deutsch- und all diesen schmerz
nachempfinden was hier
heutzutage empfinden
und was ist mit der mitgliedschaft in
der eu
die regierungen
die unsere mitgliedschaft im gegenüber
nicht unterstützen
auf reformen hin die noch passieren
müssten
sie betrachten
über unsere armin zugesprochen hat
hier wurde uns gesagt dass wir nicht
genug starke armee haben
genauso wie mit der clique
mitgliedschaft in der eu
das ist ja verhältnis zu uns wir werden
nicht als gleichwertig betrachtet
was ist mit den hohen gaspreisen die
immer noch höher werden warum ist es
dennoch wichtig dass wir
bei portieren
wissen sie es gibt so bestimmte werte
die man sehr schwer erklären kann
bis man das im eigenen land im eigenen
haus und in der eigenen familie eine
krieg hat
dann denkst du dann vergisst du alles
dann denkst du nicht mehr an die reform
bringt nicht dass du ein hund kaufen
wollte oder an die renovierung
denkst nicht mehr an die preiserhöhungen
auf gas oder strom oder benzin du denkst
nicht daran
was die regierung macht das du sparen
willst um in den urlaub zu fahren
du denkst nicht mehr an dass die steuern
jedes jahr erhöht werden
dass die regierung deine stimme nicht
hören
alles all das rückt in den hintergrund
wenn der krieg ausbricht
das ist nicht wichtig hat keine
priorität
das glück liegt daran dass du liebst
[Musik]
das ist der wahre
wert das leben das du am leben bist dass
du nicht ermordet wird und das ist die
aufgabe des landes die einfachen werte
also das leben zu verteidigen
wir haben jetzt andere prioritäten und
das wünsche ich auch
der bevölkerung in deutschland
dass wir die wahren prioritäten und die
wand ihr warnt werte im leben verfolgen
und das ihr auch dass sie auf keinen
fall in unserer situation mal sind
das ist auch mir ganz
wir sterben auch für sie auch für ihre
freiheit
was sagte zur forderung die
unabhängigkeit von den button das zu
akzeptieren
und das creme zu russland gibt
was sind sie bereit zu warten und den
fliegen her zu tun hat
ist ja nicht die frage was ich ihm geben
kann als so putin
es ist ein dialog eine verhandlung in
jeder verhandlung ist mein ziel den
krieg mit russland
zu beenden
und dafür bin ich bereit zu bestimmen
ich bin bereit verhandlungen zu führen
und bin bereit auf kompromisse
einzugehen aber diese dürfen nicht der
verrat meines landes seien
und auch die
gegenseite muss zu kompromissen bereit
sein
deswegen heißen sie ja kompromiss
nur so kommen wir aus dieser situation
heraus
das beste für uns erfolg
über details ist das noch zu schwer und
zu kurz und zu reden
wir haben ja noch keinen direkten
kontakt zwischen den präsidenten gehabt
und diesen krieg könnt ihr nun mit dem
direkten gesprächen zwischen den zwei
präsidenten beenden
herr präsident
was sagen ihre kinder
meine kinder sagen ich soll hier bleiben
sie sollen ihre wunderschöne zeit der
kindheit nicht der vier verschwenden um
ihren vater zu überzeugen das eigene
land zu verlassen
ich weiß was ich tun muss danke herr
präsident
von hier an den ukrainischen präsidenten
der ukraine helden flummi selensky bei
paul ronzheimer paul was für ein
interview exklusiv heute hier bei bild
dass du vor wenigen minuten
aufgezeichnet hat das müssen wir noch
mal sagen live darf das nicht sein aus
sicherheitsgründen weil eben niemand
wissen soll wo se lenski sich gerade
jetzt zur minute zur stunde aufhält wir
haben euch beide gerade in diesem
interview sitzen sie ihn auf einer
treppe auf dem teppich ganz einfach du
unter präsident sagen uns was ist das
für ein mensch
ja ich habe mir so lenz geht schon ein
paar mal getroffen aber jedes mal aufs
neue bin ich verwundert wie wenig er
rüberkommt wie einer der konventionellen
präsidenten sage ich einmal wie einer
der regierungschefs die ich auch schon
interviewt habe in der vergangenheit in
vielen ländern auf der welt sie lenski
man merkt gar nicht so richtig wenn er
um die ecke kommt da ist zumindest in
diesem gebäude nicht eine große
sicherheitstruppe um ihn herum die steht
dann etwas weiter entfernt er ist sehr
entspannt immer noch erstaunlicher weise
zumindest drumherum um dieses interview
du musst dir das so vorstellen in diesem
gebäude neben fall waren wir im
präsidenten gebäude immer noch sandsäcke
überall in teilen überall dunkel auch
dort wo wir saßen teilweise die emporen
mit sams hätten dort gefüllt und er
kommt um die ecke und sagt es mal
ist er ist ok wat do you sleep das sind
so die dinge wo schlafen sie wo sind sie
runtergekommen kiel wie geht es ihnen
also er ist jemand der tatsächlich eine
große empathie gegenüber menschen mit
bringt natürlich ist als schauspieler
darauf trainiert kann man so sagen also
aber er schafft es ja in einer weise
rüber zu kommen wo man nicht sofort das
gefühl hat das ist jetzt irgendwie der
arrogante regierungschefs dem gegenüber
steht und dass insbesondere in so einer
situation wir dürfen nicht vergessen in
welcher situation der ist deswegen auf
meine frage ob er überhaupt schlafen
kann was seine familie zu ihm sagt er
kleine kinder und die ganzen ja die
ganze last dieser dieses krieges liegt
auf seinen schultern die ganze last denn
er wird jetzt in den nächsten tagen
entscheiden müssen kämpfen wir weiter
oder geben wir auf und man spürt diese
last irgendwie in diesem moment nicht
das vermittelt sich in diesem bild
zumindest nicht diese ganze belastung
andere präsidenten würden sich
vielleicht jetzt an der front dauern
fotografieren lassen mit waffen in der
hand auf dem panzer sitzen er sitzt dort
einfach mit dir auf der treppe in diesem
moment ich finde ein ganz besonderer
moment er sagt dann wir sind aus eisen
wir sind eisern und das wirklich wie
eine leere durchhalteparole das wirkt
realität sind wie wahrheit in dem moment
ja so ist es und tatsächlich habe ich
ihn auch so wahrgenommen als dass die
option dass sozusagen die ukraine hier
weiter krieg führt oder sich weiter
verteidigt muss man ja viel mehr sagen
weiterhin klar auf dem tisch liegt ist
es nicht so dass ich das gefühl habe
dass das jetzt sozusagen die letzten
tage die letzten stunden möglicherweise
sind bevor der präsident
kapituliert ganz im gegenteil ich glaube
tatsächlich dass beide möglichkeiten
weiterhin auf dem tisch lägen die eine
ist und das hat er angesprochen ein
kompromiss zu finden aber sind sg hat in
einem interview auch klar gesagt auch
die andere seite muss zu kompromissen
bereit sein es kann nicht sein dass die
ukraine alles hergibt gegenüber dem
aggressor gegenüber wladimir putin und
putin bleibt bei dem was am anfang
gesagt hat und das muss man immer wieder
holen klar hat ja gesagt die ukraine
existiert gar nicht sondern gehört zu
russland das war putins ansage zu binden
beginn des krieges aber selensky
versucht natürlich auf verschiedenen
wegen jetzt etwas zu tun auch als wir
dort waren im präsidentenpalast immer
wieder hat er dann auch sein handy mal
geschaut hin und wieder da kommen anrufe
die ganze zeit von staatschefs natürlich
auf der ganzen welt die versuchen wollen
ihn jetzt in eine bestimmte richtung zu
tun und dann waren wir kurz draußen in
einem anderen raum nach dem interview
dann kann man auch mal rein gerannt war
das ein berater sprechen wollte also das
sind nervöse stunden natürlich dort in
diesem moment im präsidentenpalast als
wir dort war das heißt während ihr
gesprochen habt haben dort andere
staatschefs andere regierungschefs
angerufen auf seinem handy
ja so hat es mir hinterher berichtet
weil er an einem moment sind handy
rausgeholt und da kann man eine website
eine sms gerade an aber er hatte wegen
des interviews keine zeit zu antworten
ich kann dir nicht sagen wer dort gerade
sozusagen angerufen hat oder eine
nachricht geschrieben dabei hatte er
davon gesprochen das ist eben dass er
ständig anrufe und nachrichten natürlich
von staats- und regierungschefs bekommt
das interessante ist auch die ukraine
versuchen so ein bisschen sich
abzuschotten gerade zumindest was die
verhandlungen angeht also es gibt diese
verhandlungsgruppe die mit russland
spricht aber wir hören zum beispiel dass
andere europäische staaten gar nicht so
wirklich wissen was dort gesprochen wird
und die wollen natürlich wissen was dort
gesprochen wird aber die ukraine wollen
das erst mal für sich behalten und das
einwand der immer an seiner seite ist
andrea marx das war ein mann der auch
schon mit ihm als er als schauspieler
unterwegs war sein anwalt war über
jahrzehnte kann man sagen und der ist
dort immer im bereich zu sehen und auch
viele junge leute junge aktivisten die
mit ihm damals 20 17 20 20 19 in innen
des präsidenten gebäude gezogen sind die
sieht man dort auch teilweise auch in
camouflage mittlerweile eine irre szene
die sich dort abspielt kein danke paul
ronzheimer nach diesem beeindruckenden
interview mit dem ukrainischen
präsidenten mit flottem ihre selensky
der einsatz in diesem interview gesagt
hat der einem gänsehaut macht wir
sterben auch für euch paul über diesen
satz werden wir weiter nachher sprechen
eine ganz kurze pause danke für dein
interview